opposition candidate Carlos and Guam is
running for mayor in a particular
district of Cameroon's economic capital
Douala
the 5th district our campaign slogan
it's time for action action in
opposition to talks because in cameroon
politicians all we do is talk a lot but
do little and Guam has some convincing
to do the 5th district is home to many
people displaced from the finding and
Cameroon's mainly english-speaking
Anglophone regions they've lost trust in
a political system they feel excluded
from most of Cameroon is french-speaking
so in the fifth District they shout
power something they don't have at home
they say which started off as a protest
against the government insisting on
having French teachers in schools in the
english-speaking regions has turned into
an often violent separatist movement
various armed groups call these regions
rich in aural golden bauxite Amba zhonya
human rights organizations accused both
separatist and the military of torture
beheadings and kidnappings that charged
the government and separatists deny but
the fighting has left almost a million
people displaced and in need of
assistance this was a crisis that could
easily be averted if the government was
sincere in it in its intentions and if
the government cared about well-being of
ordinary communes the situation would
never have been allowed to descend into
the kind of chaos that we find obviously
today the situation has become so
complicated that a quick fix is almost
impossible president Paul Diaz attempts
for dialogue with a separatist failed
with some armed groups divided among
themselves and now fighting each other
in December Parliament passed a bill to
give greater autonomy to the
english-speaking regions not enough says
separatists on social media they've
caught on voters to boycott the upcoming
legislative elections in protests
destroying some of the polling stations
those who have the most at stake in this
election of the political parties and
the voters it's up to the parties to
convince the electorate to come out and
vote but the main opposition party is
also boycotting the election
we need to listen to the Anglophone
community including the extremists to
tell them you are taking the wrong path
because no election can take place in a
divided cameroon mayoral candidate in
guam and others are trying to drum up
support among the english-speaking
community to get as many people out to
vote because even before polls open the
outcome is already being contested
nicholas hawk al jazeera